hello it's my day this is a Sky News
Cost of Living special program an hour
of insight into the state of the UK
economy and the extraordinary political
events that are shaping it
well on hand are our panel of experts to
give their analysis we're joined by our
city editor Mark Kleinman our business
presenter Ian King also with us our
Deputy political editor Sam Coates and
our economics and data editor Ed Conway
and coming up today
the chancellor meets Britain's biggest
lenders as mortgage costs spiral
leading economists warned that stealth
taxes will outweigh any benefits for
people from the mini budget
oil prices rocket as the UK prepares to
set out a plan to keep the lights on
this winter
and an embattled prime minister heads to
Europe after a bruising week at home
[Music]
good afternoon we start this Sky News
Costa living special program with
mortgages and the chancellor has been
meeting the UK's leading Banks and
building societies this morning after
his economic plans sparked turmoil in
the mortgage sector on the day of
quasi-coating's so-called mini budget
September the 23rd the average mortgage
interest rate was 4.7 since then the
two-year fixed mortgage rate has
increased climbing to 5.75 on Monday and
by yesterday the average rate for a
two-year fixed mortgage hit
6.07 percent for the first time since
the 2008 financial crash well let's
bring in our city editor Mark Kleinman
who broke the story about this this
meeting that wasn't necessarily publicly
known uh before before we told the world
about it yesterday
um what what do you think that the
chancellor what kind of reception do you
think he's going to get from the bankers
well the meeting was due to wrap up
around about now Jane and the clear
agenda from the banking industry is to
communicate to quasi-quarting the
chancellor that there are real problems
in Britain's mortgage market and they
are not the fault of the financiers uh
what we saw after that mini budget of
course was real instability in financial
markets and that has led to difficulties
for banks in pricing those Home Loans to
Consumers which is in turn meant that
hundreds of mortgage deals over the last
couple of weeks have been withdrawn or
Frozen now a couple of the key issues
that the banks wanted to talk to the
chancellor about today were a request to
extend something called the mortgage
guarantee scheme which was put in place
by the government last year and
underwrite some of the losses on loans
Home Loans the first time buyers the
other issue though is a bit more nuanced
in the sense that it relates to a piece
of Regulation that's being brought in by
this City Watchdog the financial
conducts Authority which is called the
consumer Duty and what banks are worried
about is that if is that if they are
extending home loans with mortgage rates
as you pointed out uh spiking so sharply
to rates we haven't seen to levels we
haven't seen for 15 years or so are
these Banks going to be held liable
under this new FCA rule for uh issuing
mortgages to Consumers who can't afford
to repay them so lots of tension almost
certainly during this meeting in the
last hour or so we'll get a readout a
summary no doubt of what has been
discussed over the next couple of hours
but but clearly there are real issues
from the banking industry side in just
how the mortgage Market in Britain is
going to be restored to something like
normality so the chancellors you know
wants to know why they're putting up
mortgage rates so so much what he'll
also be wanting to know presumably if
any of these higher rates are going to
be passed on to people with savings as
well because they don't seem to have
risen in the same rate well there's been
this perennial mismatch that we've we've
talked about many many times between the
the loans the interest rates that are
charged to uh consumers on loans like
mortgages and those that are paid to to
ordinary Savers
um that's something that no doubt will
have been uh pressed upon the banks by
the uh by the treasury uh during these
talks this morning uh and there are a
number of other issues including the
fact that quasi-cotting is due to unveil
a big package of City reforms later on
this month whether that is still going
to go ahead as a result of the turmoil
that we saw in financial markets last
week remained open to question so
interest rates going up for mortgages
fewer mortgages out there on the market
we can understand their head but that
the mortgage burden is also going up can
you just explain what that means yeah
it's it's worth remembering that
obviously we talk a lot about kind of
official interest rates but there's the
difference between that and what you
know you end up we all end up paying on
our mortgages or indeed on savings
accounts as you're saying let me just
kind of go through some of that because
it's been you know there's been some
enormous changes really just over the
course of the last uh few weeks and what
we can do is just we'll show you some of
those changes
um look at this first of all this is
this is the Bank of England base rate
well they actually call the bank rate
these days and this is what's happened
to it up and talk of where we are now so
that's kind of where we are at the
moment 2.25
it's a it's a small technical thing but
if you're such a Pity while you're
showing us your grass there we are yeah
you as well okay now I hope you can hear
me now okay because uh this is actually
this is really genuinely quite important
what's going on here is uh this is the
Bank of England's uh official rate and
that's where we are at the moment 2.25
so two two and a quarter percent and
what I'm going to show you here is kind
of where markets and Traders people
within the market expected it to go uh
in the coming years so this is where the
expectation was uh back in February so I
mean it's kind of extraordinary isn't it
to think about how much things have
changed since then back then people who
are making bets on this stuff only
thought they was going to go up to 1.75
and inflation was already starting to
kind of rear its head at that point but
look at what's happened since then so
what we're looking into the future here
over the future uh what people think is
going to happen to interest rates that
was in February then it went up to about
2.75 in August remember this is just
expectations but this feeds in to the
mortgage costs that we're all paying
because it goes into something called
swaps rates uh you're talking about the
kind of costs that mortgage lenders look
at when they're working out how to price
their mortgages and then by early
September obviously we had the new Liz
trust government by that point no one
was 100 sure what they were going to do
clearly as it turned out but by then
already the cost of borrowing in terms
of the expectations where it was going
was up to 4.75 for bank rate uh next
year so you can see this getting higher
and higher and higher the cost of Brian
going higher even before the mini budget
but look at what happened next so then
came the mini budget and then last week
that went up to a peak of 6.1 percent
I'll show you in a second and why that
matters so much the good news is since
then it has come down a fair uh bit well
I say a fair bit it's in between the two
at the moment it's about 5.5 is where
markets currently expect those rates to
go and that could obviously yo-yo around
but the big difference is really the
comparison with where we were only at
the start of the year and where we are
now that's a big difference and when you
look and basically look at what's
available on the markets you see that
that stuff's actually already starting
to feed through so what this is just
showing you is a moment ago Jane was
talking about the kind of average rate
that's available on a two-year fixed
rate mortgage well this is basically it
going all the way back to 2008 and you
can see look around
2007-2008 it was up at around six seven
percent so really high in comparison
with where it was subsequently look the
era of cheap money cheap mortgages in
comparison with much of history but look
at what's happened recently it was
climbing up before this mini budget
before Liz trust was elected it was
getting up to around that kind of four
percent Mark but look what happen
subsequently look at that line now up to
6.07 it's actually kind of a little bit
uh potentially since then and that is
the highest that we've seen uh since
2008 and here's why that's significant
as Jane was saying a second ago it's not
just about this race it's also about
other factors it's about how much debt
you have it's about how high your income
is in comparison with your mortgage
repayments and that shows your ability
to repay it that's the important thing
so the chart we really need to look at
is not that it's an affordability chart
and I've got one here as it so happens
which shows you the mortgage burden and
the higher this line is basically the
more of your income you're paying on
your mortgage each month this is for New
Deals okay and the couple of things to
note here okay that was just before the
last financial crisis really getting
pretty high there
um that was the period in the late 80s
early 90s before we had an enormous
housing crash negative equity it was
really a really terrible time probably
the most Torrid housing Christ crisis
we've had in this uh in this country but
look here it was really low recently you
know we've been living through quite a
kind of you know fortunate time in terms
of mortgage payments um but look at what
happens subsequently so before before
the many budget these rates in terms of
the available rates out there and how
much they dig into your income that have
risen to the highest level since 2008 so
it was already getting quite high but
then look what happened next okay then
came the mini budget and that went up to
the highest level that we've seen since
the early uh 1990s late 1980s up to
about 27 of your income and that's the
real concern it's the fact that we're
looking at the burden remember we had
similar charts to this when we're
looking at Energy prices just how much
they were digging into your average
income
it's the same thing with the mortgages
Jane and I think that's the issue you
know we've already been talking about a
cost of living crisis for quite some
time but now there's this mortgage
element on top of the energy bit on top
of the fact that inflation's really high
and that people are quite squeezed at
the moment so so if you look you you
were you were paying say for a new
mortgage 15 of your household income two
years ago yeah now you're paying 30 yeah
I think it's up for about six exactly
it's an enormous increase up from about
16 to 27 that's a big chunk that's a big
jump Ian let's bring it in King now a
city presenter and editor and both you
know if if the mortgage burden goes up
both of the times has gone up really
high in the past it's just before a
financial crash should we be worried
well I don't think there's any as I said
to you when we we've had this program
last week I I find it inconceivable that
you're not going to get a fall in house
prices in this country given the extent
to which the mortgage burden is going to
rise don't forget that over between now
the end of next year getting on for 1.8
million households are going to come off
fixed rate mortgage deals uh they've
either got to find a new one which as
Mark was explaining it's going to be
quite difficult because there are a few
projects on on the market and of course
they're going to be paying a lot more
their interest rate the burden of
servicing that mortgage is going to go
up pretty substantially so under those
circumstances I find it inconceivable
that house prices aren't going to fall
and if you look around the world that's
actually been the evidence already if
you take for example New Zealand where
the Central Bank there has been raising
rates pretty aggressively at a faster
Pace they've come from a lower base even
than we did in the UK where only 10
months ago we were at 0.1 for bank rate
the New Zealand Central Bank has raised
a lot more aggressively than the bank of
England and you've seen house prices in
New Zealand falling for about the last
last eight or nine months Australia too
similar kind of situation going on there
that was partly because there was a
bubble in those markets but it's it's
inconceivable I think that there won't
be some sort of crack in the housing
market I mean you know you can overdo
the Doom and Gloom and say well
potentially this is going to be a crash
and you know that word like crash you've
got to define a what a crash actually
means in terms of percentage Falls if
someone say it's a correction yeah you
could say that I mean not so fast
recently yeah there's a bit of it but
it's still we haven't we haven't really
had a moment like that for a while no I
mean in the late 1980s of course there
was a very very specific uh Factor uh
because basically the chancellor in 1988
Nigel Lawson we used to have this thing
called myris mortgage interest rate
relief at source so uh you've got tax
relief on a percentage of your mortgage
payments Gordon branded away with it in
1997 but in 1988 there was a special
kink in it that Nigel Lawson said he was
going to change which basically enabled
two couple two people in the couple
today blame Moira Myra so as joint
relief Lawson said he was going to do
away with that but instead of doing it
overnight which is what a lot of budget
policy measures do he said we're going
to do this in a few months time so of
course that gave the housing boom in the
late 80s one more big spurt upwards and
that was why the correction afterwards
was a crash
um that's
that's sound codes at Deputy political
editor and you've been up there at the
two-party conferences over the last
couple of weeks
um in in terms of of how hard it is for
people getting mortgages now is there a
plan from the government to help not
really I mean I've just come back from
Birmingham where we've had five days of
the conservative party conferences uh
conference and what's really striking
talking to members of the cabinet about
exactly this is just how unprepared they
were for this conversation about
mortgages and on and on one level you
can kind of understand it so today is
the one month anniversary of Liz trust
becoming prime minister and my God what
a month uh it's been and she came in to
office facing a cost of living crisis
but that cost of living crisis was all
about energy and energy prices and and
what she determined was that she felt
that the consumer could not face an
additional thousand pounds a year on
their bills on top of the already higher
level uh of energy costs that they were
um that they were facing so that there
is now 160 billion pounds plan to deal
with that but after about three weeks of
a government it's quite clear that
there's another cost of living tsunami
on the way in the form of these uh
higher mortgage costs that's going to
result not only a thousand pounds a year
but hundreds and hundreds of pounds a
month now if the government determined
that a thousand pounds a year was too
much on one in one area
the natural Assumption of many I think
was that there might be some help coming
down the track uh when you're dealing
with costs even higher than that but but
but there isn't and and in some way
you've got I got a lot of different
contradictory uh thoughts when it comes
to the mortgage Market some cabinet
ministers want to actually blame the
bank of England for not putting up rates
earlier and now having to put up rates
more but the problem with that is that
when the city sees them do that they
think that makes the entire Financial
system more risky and actually prices
start going up so you're in a sort of
Doom spiral so actually the Prime
Minister and the chancellor now feel
that they can't do that they can't blame
the bank of England even though as they
look to sort of Shield themselves
politically on this issue uh they uh
they would really really like to I think
but but you saw that from Liz truss and
quasi quoting speech that they come
world but more importantly the question
is what can they do
and the answer is there isn't really
very much money one of the big problems
one of the reasons that we're talking
about all of this is that in her first
few weeks in government this small state
conservative has borrowed an
astronomical amount in order to fund
that energy price scheme and the market
is worried about that level of borrowing
which so it stands to reason that you
can't borrow a lot more of course there
are other things around the margin that
you could do but there is no plan to
give direct fiscal direct financial help
to people there just isn't the scope to
do that and so right now in the treasury
they're doing as Mark was describing
sort of looking at everything they
possibly can to help but the bottom line
is that there aren't many options
available and it just isn't much money
left
and they don't know what to do
it's quite a gloomy way to to pause the
first section of this
um but pause it we are going to uh
you're watching a sky newscaster living
special program coming up
meeting Connor's warned that the stealth
taxes will outweigh any benefits from
the Chancellor's mini budget as Sam was
just touching on we're going to discuss
more of that next
[Music]
[Music]
within minutes and now it's coming from
both sides and it's moving this way
[Music]
all right
only about half a mile from the Turkish
coast and it's evident that there's the
boat seriously overcrowded this is one
of the most severe viruses in the world
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
ance
that's it it got us then there's a lot
of action going on
a lot of still
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail look at her arms I can put my
entire hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
[Music]
Mother Nature is can be vicious
absolutely Savage
[Music]
I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake OH
[Music]
close and personality
this is what makes the job
welcome back to this Sky News Cost of
Living special program let's consider
now whether the government's plans will
make us worse or better off and there is
a warning today from some leading
economists that freezes to tax and
Welfare thresholds will outweigh any
benefits people get from the
Chancellor's mini budget over time the
respected Institute for fiscal studies
estimates that two pounds are going to
be lost for every pound gained through
the government's personal tax cuts well
let's bring in our economics and data
editor at Conway and we were just
talking about mortgage payments going up
which in some ways balances out that any
help that households may get about
energy bills is what the ifs is saying
here right that in the long term we are
going to lose more from from freezers
than we are from what the government is
giving us back in any of the giveaways
in its main budget well in short and
short yes and it's not it's this is a
pretty kind of old and tried and trusted
way of the government trying to raise
money if you if you could have like
remember the Gordon Brown era people
used to talk about this a lot they
called it fiscal drag and the idea was
that you know as people get a bit better
off and as prices go up their their
earnings go up and their spending goes
up but the thresholds at which they
start paying tax often don't get
increased in line with those things and
that's basically what the ifs is talking
about here we've got very high inflation
in the country you're going to have much
higher wage inflation than was
previously expected as a result you've
got more people earning more money
whether that money is going as far as
another question of course we talked
about you know the cost of living crisis
and inflation and so on but for the tax
system from its perspective you are over
a certain threshold and there are
various different thresholds at the
moment at which you start paying tax and
also there are other thresholds like
benefits thresholds and as you earn more
you start to fall into those higher rate
thresholds and what they've calculated
is that more and more people are going
to end up paying those higher rates more
and more people are going to get caught
in uh paying more tax and as a result of
that
basically for every pound that you see
your income go up you've got about two
pounds of it going down as a result of
having to pay extra tax so there is I
mean it's a paradox here you know
talking about this tax cutting
government well in practice and this and
uh you know when you look at the tax
burden so the total amount of tax we're
paying as a percentage of GDP it's worth
noting that despite those changes that
Liz trust uh has introduced in the mini
budget or quasi quota
um that that tax burden is still going
to get up to the highest level since the
1940s regardless so you know it's partly
as a result of these kinds of measures
uh that to some extent well actually
kind of enormously swamp the changes
that we've had in tax in taxes so tax
cuts go down in terms of the rates but
the amount that you end up paying goes
up because you're kind of pulled into
those higher thresholds more quickly
because inflation and wage inflation are
going yes it's the the ifs saying that
if you're on a if you're a basic rate
taxpayer you'll probably be paying about
an extra 500 pounds and if you're a
higher rate taxpayer you're probably
paying about an extra 30 three thousand
pounds in both sort of cancer but that
but the but the other kind of point that
they make is that when you look across
the kind of income spectrum and this is
something obviously that as we know is
the case from those all the measures uh
the tax cuts that we've had uh even
after the 45p rate abolition has been
canceled still it is higher earners that
benefit more as a result of those
changes to to income tax and obviously
the cancellation of the Health and
Social care Levy but it's a similar
thing when it comes to these uh the
fiscal drag it also uh tends to
um be as a percentage of your income it
tends to affect those who are kind of
lower down in the Spectrum when you look
at everything uh all told
um so that's just kind of one part of
but the problem really is that we're
still
we still only have one part of the
picture when it comes to the
government's fiscal plans and that's
going to be the interesting thing is you
know we are going to later on this month
it was supposed to be the end of towards
the end of next month but later on this
month we're going to get more detail
from them and at the moment it's hard to
tell just how generous how tough it's
going to be are we going to be able to
describe this as austerity it looks like
probably we will but we don't have the
details on that yet and that again feeds
into why Market's quite nervous at the
moment they don't know enough let's
bring our city editor mark clyman
because we're talking about the real
squeeze on personal finances according
to the ifs it's it's business
insolvencies as well isn't it they're
predicting that they're going to go up
so it's not just you know the pan in
people's pockets when they get home yeah
I talked to a lot of people in the
insolvency world Jane people who handle
the administrations and liquidations of
companies and it's actually been a
relatively benign period in terms of
particularly in terms of larger
companies
um going by the wayside
um over the last year or two actually
there was a wave of big bankruptcies
during the initial phase of the covid
crisis because obviously with the High
Street badly affected by by lockdowns
and so on but actually since then it's
been relatively quiet that is definitely
going to change the restructuring
practitioners professionals that I speak
to are anticipating a deluge of
corporate insolvences in the coming
um 12 months or so and there will be
some big names big casualties that we'll
see as part of that in the High Street
Industrial users of of energy heavy
industrial users of energy I mean at the
weekend I reported that British steel
which is Britain's second biggest steel
producer has gone cap in hand to the
government to ask for a bailout
approximating to roughly half a billion
pounds because it cannot fund its energy
costs Still project steel prices uh
globally have come down and so it's
struggling to make ends meet and I think
we are going to see a lot of those sorts
of examples materializing over the next
year or so
at growth we had less Trust
with growth and
her party conference can you have growth
without cuts I mean that someone always
has to suffer if someone else is growing
presumably
well that takes you into a very sticky
debate about how much public spending is
is actually productive and I suspect and
this is gets to the knob of it the
government obviously wants to rebase
benefits so they rise in line with
average earnings rather than inflation
and there's even members of the
government like Ian Duncan Smith have
pointed out you are going to be taking
money out of people's pockets
effectively if you do that so it's
really quite difficult I mean you get
back to things like efficiency gains and
more effective procurement and I mean
this was something that the Coalition
was looking at 10 years ago you know so
Philip green was brought in by David
Cameron to look at how the NHS was
spending its money and could it be
buying things more efficiently as a way
of saving money and and he did actually
come up with a really interesting report
that uh you know highlighted for example
the number of fax machines that were
still being used in the NHS and sort of
obsolete technology so it's it's really
about running government more
efficiently rather than actually trying
to make hard and fast cuts and at the
same time you've got all these calls on
the public purse you know defense
spending is clearly going to have to go
up in the wake of Putin's aggression in
Ukraine
um the education system has been really
really starved of funding over the last
10 years there's a problem in the
judicial system which is while the
barristers are out on strike right now
there are there are backlogs in the
courts anyway because of covid so it's
it's a really really tough call and I
know a small state politician like Liz
Trussell quasiquarting will say well
it's there's always cuts that can be
found and probably there are but don't
forget the Coalition had a good old go
at this a decade ago there's probably
not that much fat to be cut in in many
cases and that's the problem for the
government isn't it you know they've
made these policies and as we see we've
got nurses striking today over their pay
and at the same time we've got a
government that says let's remove the
cap on Bankers bonuses it's the Optics
aren't aren't great on a very simple
level are they some City 24 hours since
Liz just basically outlined her vision
for government and it's a lot of
promises in that and the big headline
promise is high growth but lower taxes
she mentioned taxes 20 times in Her
speech and the core of her argument was
if we lower taxes people will work more
keep more of their money it's absolutely
Central to her vision so I suspect a lot
of faces woke up and thought what Earth
is going on here that all the front
pages have uh information about how I've
got a higher tax burden coming down the
track and I just heard a speech from the
Prime Minister about how she wants to
lower taxes and of course what are the
political problems that she's got one of
the reasons that the tax burden is going
up is because as well as doing the
things in the mini budget like reversion
National Insurance increase she has
inherited all the decisions that Boris
Johnson and Richie sunax government made
and that's the reason the tax the tax
burden is going up because overall since
the start of the parliament the
cumulative decisions in the last three
and a half years add up to an increase
in taxes rather than a lowering and and
there is a problem for Liz truss here
it's called a lot of stuff she says she
doesn't like but she's still having to
do uh because she inherited it like a
windfall tax she's against windfall
taxes but just what happened she's
having to carry one out and impose one
because that she has inherited from the
last government and and overall Ian is
completely right there is a big question
about how you make this all add up yes
there's going to be a drive for
efficiency savings there are all sorts
of Treasury tricks you can deploy I
suspect very soon they're going to raise
the age at which you uh can start
claiming the state pension uh other uh
accounting almost accounting tricks uh
that you can do like that but in the end
I'm not sure the markets think that you
can deliver big spending cuts because
Tory MPS will stop them and the only
thing I am told by some Business Leaders
that they will trust the only
announcements that it will trust that
mean the state gets smaller the baron
gets under control is if there are more
tax Rises and that is completely
politically impossible for this trust
wow
um you're watching a Sky News Cost of
Living special program coming up oil
prices rocket as the UK prepares to set
out a plan to keep the lights on this
winter we'll discuss that after the next
break
[Music]
[Music]
amazing
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
welcome back to the Sky News Cost of
Living special program let's talk about
energy prices now the price of crude oil
hit a three-week high this morning as
the OPEC plus group of Nations agreed
its biggest Supply cut since 2020. it's
contributed to a fall in the pound and
comes just hours before the National
Grid prepares to outline how it plans to
deal with a harsh winter and keep the
UK's lights on well let's unpick some of
that with Ian King and and he just
explain remind us who OPEC are and and
why are they saying what they're saying
today so OPEC the cartel of oil
producing companies dominated by Saudi
Arabia but also including countries like
Iran Iraq Libya Venezuela the United
Arab Emirates and OPEC plus is those
countries plus Russia and and Allied oil
producers and effectively they try to
control the price of oil they count all
together for something like 44 of global
oil production and viewers with a very
long memory will remember the role that
they played in the 1970s uh oil crisis
yeah and and so they I want to produce
less how would producing less of
something forcing up the prices help an
energy crisis ah well depends on uh how
you view an energy crisis I mean as far
as OPEC are concerned they're very very
worried the price has fallen uh it Peaks
at just over 125 on the 31st of May
Since Fallen by 33 it was flirting with
84 dollars a barrel last week and the
Saudis the key player in OPEC are not
very happy about this and interestingly
they've been supported in this by Russia
now Russia so they're not making enough
money fundamentally so they're saying
we're not making enough money we're
going to stop making it so it costs more
exactly yeah they want to restrict uh
supplies and the Russians are equally uh
in favor of this Russia can't get its
crude onto Western markets anymore
because of the embargoes that have been
imposed they're selling it to the
Chinese and the Indians primarily but
it's a significant discount like you're
talking 30 off in some cases so the
Russians again to see the headline price
rise as well so they will get more money
flowing in for the to chiefly to finance
the war against Ukraine so that is one
concern and of course the other concern
is you mentioned the war in Ukraine lots
of countries in Europe are struggling
with supplies for energy generally
we're expecting to get an announcement
today on the British energy Supply over
the winter I mean is there a concern
that the lights could effectively have
to be turned off at some point
the margin there is so National Grid
which is the systems operator they're
the they're the people that ensure that
they're supply and demand in the
electricity market and the gas markets
they'd be publishing their winter
Outlook they have in the past warned of
the possibility of a blackout you talk
to most analysts in the sector and they
say it's increasingly unlikely I mean
blackouts are very very rare in this
country and increasingly where they do
happen it's not due to shortages in
generation it's it's problems with the
transmission system most people don't
think black ads are likely this winter
however if you get an exceptionally cold
winter and the wind doesn't blow and the
sun doesn't shine and Renewables output
comes down and then you get a couple of
uh the remaining nuclear power plants
going offline because of Maintenance
work is required then potentially you
are in in difficulties but the key point
is the UK is in quite a good situation
with gas compared with Continental
Europe we have our own North Sea
supplies we have under ground cables
that to bring it in from the Netherlands
and from Norway we've got uh liquid
liquefied National Gas terminals several
of those dotted around the country so
it's fairly easy to land and regassify
LNG sources in a way that a lot of
Continental European countries just
don't have
Mark how how is this affecting effective
Retail Energy suppliers the people that
you and I pay our bills to and that heat
our houses well what we saw last year
James was dozens of the suppliers to
British households going bust the spike
in wholesale gas prices really caught
them out many of them weren't hedged as
in their hand bought insurance against
the risk of rising prices and so we saw
roughly 30 of them going bust now the
biggest of those was a company called
bulb energy excuse me at about 1.7
million customers and that effectively
had to be nationalized temporarily by
the government because it was so large
that it couldn't be resolved using the
industry regulator off gems use your
scheme for just passing on those
customers to other suppliers now Bob has
been in that sort of zombie-like State
as a ward of the government for the best
part of a year now and the cost of
funding bulb for the British taxpayer
has been several billion pounds and
we'll find out a bit more about the
exact cost in the coming months but a
sale of bulb to a company called octopus
energy which is another of the big
emerging fast growing suppliers that
looks likely to take place in the next
few weeks which will at least get bulb
off the taxpayers books nevertheless the
cost to produce taxpayers of having
bailed out this company is going to be
several billion pounds and what about
what I think that indicates is that
despite the fact that we've got this
enormous energy uh you know pricing
scheme that was announced by the
government several several weeks ago
there are still risks if wholesale Mark
prices Spike again there are still risks
to a number of the other remaining
energy suppliers in the UK and that's
going to cause yet more headaches for
Jacob rees-mogg the new business and
Energy Secretary yeah and the last thing
consumers want if you know if they're
worried about the cost of their bills is
worrying about whether their supply is
going to go bust as well and Sam in
terms of what the government can do to
help people who are worried about this
they've they've announced this these
payments which are already coming off
bills I'd say I noticed my my direct
debited change and it was because the
it's it's starting to come off this
month isn't it for the first time
whether whether you want it or not
um but can the government do anything
else that's right we've had the 160
billion pound scheme but possibly the
most expensive scheme of my entire
lifetime uh in terms of a government
intervention and that's uh kept the unit
price of household bills
um and I think the government are pretty
happy with the way that that's landed
um everybody knows about that pretty
much and they talked a lot about it at
Tory conference but there's another plan
on the cards an extraordinary plan quite
frankly uh which people inside Whitehall
are looking at and when I interviewed
Liz trust two mornings ago I asked her
about it and this is a plan that would
see the UK government buy a vast amount
of Norwegian gas maybe up to 20 years
worth Norwegian gas they might do it by
duration they might do it by volume the
government looking at all sorts of
different options and Liz trust
confirmed to me on the record in an
interview we are looking at long-term
energy contract contracts with other
companies the information is out there
and I think the idea for doing this is
that Liz truss is very keen to ensure
Supply now Ian said that the chances of
uh blackouts are quite low but Liz truss
hitched her political reputation by
swearing that if she was prime minister
there wouldn't be and there's a little
nervousness that Regulators have given
some hints that this might be the case
and they are absolutely determined that
Liz trust is not seen to break a promise
and so ministers have been ordered to go
away and investigate this scheme I
believe this week the Norwegian oil
companies gas companies coming back with
suggested prices but there are two
massive problems with this the first of
all is that if you're going to buy a
huge amount of gas now that's going to
be at a price pretty close to what it is
at the moment in other words hugely
above a historic average and the gamble
that the government will be taking is
that it's better to ensure the security
of Supply because businesses want
stability even if that means a huge
premium on the amount that you're going
to spend I mean that in itself is quite
a big call if you do it for 20 years
that's binding the hands of future
governments by doing this and you are
effectively making for instance the
Norwegian government sort of an actor in
British politics because if for instance
the labor party come out and say well we
don't like this then that's quite
something uh as well but then there's
another dimension to this
these viewers listening to the first
half of this program know that this
government doesn't have much money left
it hasn't have much additional borrowing
capacity the markets are very worried
this is all going to have to be borrowed
money hundreds of billions more
borrowing with an impact on the deficit
quite what would be the reaction of the
markets to that so it's an incredibly
challenging idea that we're talking
about here there's a huge amount of not
just nervous downright fear in
government about it Liz truss uh from
her interview with me two mornings ago
quite clear we're pressing ahead looking
into it it's not signed yet they've
really said anything beyond that
interview publicly about it but we could
be on the Press but there's something
with lots and lots and lots of long-term
implications and let's bring in Ed
Conway here and you know in terms of
oil prices and energy I mean I think
we're all able to understand
that if all prices go up we're going to
be paying more for our petrol you know
it might be that we're going to be
paying more for our home energy but it
affects all sorts of other things
doesn't it it does it kind of goes into
pretty much every kind of petrochemical
product you can think of and basically
about I don't know what the statistic is
something like of 90 97 of all the
products we use or buy uh or consume
have some form of kind of chemical in
the basis of it you know whether it's
Plastics or Another Part of uh of the
makeup so it it feeds through to
everything and food as well I mean let's
not forget that fertilizer is basically
a petrochemical product it's made from
natural gas we use natural gas to to get
the kind of nitrogen out of the air the
hydrogen from that so that then you know
precipitates higher inflation the thing
that um is also a concern and it goes
back to what both Sam and Ian were
talking about is that question of Supply
um and once there's there's two things
that I find slightly unsettling going
into this winter the first is that we
seem to be pretty much the only country
in Europe that isn't talking proactively
about how to curtail intensive energy
use okay so we're going into this winter
it's very possible there'll be shortage
of gas it's very possible we get even
less gas because there's still some gas
flowing from Russia via Ukraine
ironically enough it's very possible
that gets cut off if that does
we are by far and away not the worst
country to be affected by this you know
Germany Slovakia a few other countries
particularly in Central Europe are
really in a tight spot at that point but
they have various plans that their
entire industrial base will basically
shut down if that is the case and it
will be protected we don't have that we
have the opposite of that in this
country we have a scheme which basically
says to Big energy users we're going to
cap your energy costs much as for
households and nothing about you know
try to to wean yourself off it there's a
bit of an implication you know it's only
six months so maybe try and do the best
so that is what concerns me first of all
we don't really we haven't really kind
of engaged with that and I don't know
quite why the second is if you look
actually I've got another child this is
a slightly ugly chart I'm afraid but let
me let me let's bring it up and I'll
show you just kind of quickly if you
look at the amount of gas that's kind of
either come into or gone out of oh there
it is on the on the screen you can see
it there that's the amount of gas okay
that either goes in or comes out of the
UK and anything above the line is stuff
coming going out of the UK okay so if
you look on the right hand side you see
how it's really high that's basically
we've got a lot of liquefied natural gas
LNG coming into the country we pump it
out there into the Netherlands and it
goes towards Germany and it's been
replenishing all of their tanks but the
bit that worries me are those orange
bits that are kind of down below every
single winter for as long as anyone can
remember we have relied on gas coming
across from the continents from the
Netherlands through those pipes that Ian
was talking about to supplement our
supply we we are a big part of a single
marketing energy despite the fact that
we've left the single market for for
goods we massively rely on this every
single winter especially in the in the
event of cold Winters so that's what
concerns me if there is a shortage of
gas what happens to those orange bits do
we still get the gas coming across from
the continent yes we can get more LNG
but if it's really cold
we have a genuine problem and that's and
that is what slightly alarms me very few
people talking kind of aggressively
about this within government
electricity as well I mean for months we
have been exporting electricity to
France and the French are depending on
that this Summer that their equivalence
of National Grid has published something
very much like we're going to get from
National Grid today they're counting on
UK electricity exports this winter and
yet according to the government we're
going to be importing energy from France
there's something's got to give there
and is is the concern about Supply in
terms of there might just there might
not be enough to go around or or is the
concern that display will be tight and
it will just force the prices up and
it'll become incredibly expensive the
two things are kind of intertwined and
obviously that you know the less Supply
there is the higher the price goes and
then you know industrial users for
instance can start to kind of pull back
um but the the fact that we are kind of
at the moment encouraging industrial
users to basically use more energy
whereas in on the continents industrial
users who these These are this is a big
part of my energy use are being
discouraged essentially to you from
using energy they're being given support
schemes which basically say if you kind
of switch off or curtail your usage then
we'll be able to support you by
supporting your employees the fact that
we don't have that means we are kind of
acting against the general thing we're
kind of helping person from that
perspective rather than going against
him because we are encouraging people to
use more gas which in turn needs to be
more reliant on on Russia so there is as
Ian says there's a lot of contradictions
and paradoxes here that don't seem to
have been resolved and the fear is you
know is it has it just been this summer
of so much political activity that's
meant that you know officials have been
trying to work on this but getting
decisions out of the politicians that's
been basically impossible
well we're going to be talking more
about politics and our final part
actually you're watching a Sky News Cost
of Living special program it's still to
come the pm has insisted that she just
wants to get on with a job after a
turbulent start to her Premiership but
does she have political and economic
credibility have they taken their eyes
off the ball we'll talk more after the
break
[Music]
[Music]
within minutes and now it's coming from
both sides and it's moving this way
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
I'm Alex Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul
ance
that's it it got us then there's a lot
of action going on
a lot of hits still
[Music]
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail look at her arms I can put my
entire hand round
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this Hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want Clarity in an
uncertain world
[Music]
Mother Nature is can be vicious
absolutely Savage
[Music]
I can't imagine
how much plastic is lying at the bottom
of this huge Lake OH
[Music]
close and personal with a rhino
this is what makes the job
oh my God
[Music]
welcome back Liz truss has arrived in
Prague this lunchtime as she prepares to
address European leaders about how to
tackle the prospect of gas shortages
because of the war in Ukraine amongst
other things the Prime Minister leaves
behind a divided cabinet and
conservative party as the political and
economic Fallout from our government's
mini budget continues so does she still
have political and economic credibility
she doesn't have that bunch of flowers
anymore that's for sure let's bring in
Sam coats or Deputy political editor
looks a bit like a slightly odd wedding
portrait that doesn't know Sam
um the conservatives were seen as a
party there were they were the safe
hands of the economy are they seen as
that still
um that picture possibly slightly less
awkward than lots of moments that uh
Conservative Party Conference in
Birmingham I have to say
um this trust has three audiences and
having come in halfway through a
parliament because the previous prime
minister was ejected by his own party
because he wasn't seen to uphold
standards to sufficient degree
um she was always going to come in at a
very difficult moment and it was always
going to be bumpy but there are three
audiences and she's struggling with all
three of them voters uh there are the
markets and then there are her own MPS
and if she fails at any one of those
she's in big trouble and it's a sort of
danger of a doom Loop because any one of
those uh uh being unhappy will feed
through to the others
um when it comes to the market a lot of
the problem many Tory MPS believe and
many labor MPS are now going on the
attack to claim are self-inflicted now
in the early period of Liz truss's
government there was behind the scenes a
lot of attack on Institute patient the
office for Budget responsibility the
bank of England there was the sacking of
the most senior civil servant in the
treasury all of these things unnerved
the markets and that was in addition to
the higher than expected spending in
that mini budget and I think the
combination of a willingness of uh
cabinet members to spend big and then to
hint that they were going to spend even
bigger whenever they went on telly a
sort of fiscal incontinence whenever uh
the likes of Jacob Reese morgue turned
up in the TV studio it was that whole
package that unnerved the market so now
they have this job to do in the next few
weeks whenever their statement is it's
not quite clear that it's this month
it's probably this month uh brought
forward but it's quite clear and even
that lack of clarity is worrying some so
they've got a job to do reassuring that
and they need to find spending cuts and
they need to find ways of reassuring the
market but all of those are difficult
decisions uh that we're not quite sure
about the second thing is voters have
seen the turmoil they looked at it and
they've given it a thumbs down there is
a 33 Point deficit of the conservative
party behind labor Liz truss is has got
worse poll ratings than at any point uh
uh that Boris Johnson enjoyed and
amongst key drama Graphics including
pensions the gap between labor and the
Tories always when Boris Johnson was in
power healthy Tory leads now that's all
uh that's all dwindling and both of
those things are feeding into the
opinion of the third group the most
important group in some ways in the
short term which is Tory MPS now the
biggest moment in Birmingham came at 7
20 a.m on social media and it was the
announcement by quasi-quarting that he
was abandoning the top rate of tax
abolition that 45p top rate for people
earning 150 000 pounds he was going to
abolish it now they're going to keep it
it's why that happened that really
matters it happened because there was a
Revolt Michael gave has appointed
himself the leader of the internal
opposition Grant shout all sorts of
story MPS coming out and going we don't
like what you've done stop it and even
though Liz trust Styles herself as Proto
Thatcher lady not for turning she had to
give in and give in to her party
but there are lots of other plans that
Tori MPS think are mad and they think
that having put the handcuffs on her
wants they may have to put handcuffs on
her again
and that could happen again and again
and again so we may end up effectively
with the MPS forcing it to have
effectively a sort of zombie government
and what's that going to do to the
voters and what's that going to do to
the markets and and let's bring an ed if
if it does seem that the the Prime
Minister isn't essentially in charge of
our own party as Sam is suggesting that
that doesn't then sort of auger great
economic stability does it uh well
no but by the same token she's you know
Ashley's got less in control actually
markets have got a little bit calmer so
this week they are calmer than they were
last week there's a lot going on uh
right now where is it the pound you can
see it there on your screen there's down
to what 113 but it was up at 114 uh
yesterday it's a little bit weaker but
it's it is stronger and slightly less
volatile than it was last week part of
the reason for that is that the bank of
England intervened in this extraordinary
way last week and we just got actually
just this morning a letter an
interesting letter from the Deputy
Governor their financial stability John
cunliff kind of giving a little bit more
color on the reasons they took that
decision and you'll remember we had a
story running about how uh certain kind
of funds there were within hours of
potential default or indeed having to be
uh essentially collapse
um and he has essentially confirmed this
saying it was likely that these funds
talking about ldi that kind of specific
types exactly specific types of funds
that uh uh that the pensions are
invested in would have to begin the
process of winding up in the following
morning what's also interesting from
that letter I want to show you a chart
because there's there's a chart that he
includes in there and it goes to this
point you remember this point that the
government was trying to underline that
this was an international a story of
international volatility but have a look
at this okay I'm going to get up to just
show you the lines here again this is a
chart that came from the bank of England
uh just earlier on this morning and the
key thing to look at here is the higher
these are the higher the yield is so the
higher the interest rate is and
basically you know you're having to give
people more money for for uh for
borrowing off them and what you can see
here is the the turquoise line as the UK
then you've got the US the orange one
the Euro area is purple and look how
close they all are up until 14th
September late September and then came
both the NPC decision but it looks like
more importantly that fiscal event look
at how the turquoise line the UK uh
30-year guilt yield just went way up
compared with these other lines that
basically stayed where they were really
kind of underlining the facts that in
that period this was very much a UK
specific issue you know if there were
any doubt about it it's been kind of
drummed in here by this chart from the
bank of England but then the other
critical thing is this look the bank
steps in and then the yield comes down
an awful lot still not where it was
before you still got a premium there
what's that premium a premium perhaps of
concern about what the government is
actually going to do but that I think is
the interesting thing Jane that moment
there was massive for the bank of
England and that brings me to I guess
you know quite an interesting point that
goes back to what Sam was talking about
was this the moment that those
institutions like the bank of England
like the treasury like the obr suddenly
actually paradoxically became more
powerful and more influential than they
were before Liz truss actually came
along because they've shown that they
can do stuff they can sort things out
you've got less trust going to the obr
to basically say we're going to do what
you want so it's it's a really
interesting shift here not the one that
she would have wanted no slightly
possibly the opposite to what she was
hoping to achieve very briefly Mark how
how are the markets and how businesses
reacting to this government so far what
do you say well we've talked a bit a bit
there about
um about the pounds modest recovery
since uh since that historic low of 1.3
cents a couple of weeks ago
um going back to that mini budget of a
couple of weeks ago actually it was is
important to note that many of the major
business lobbying groups uh in the UK
actually welcomed many of the supply
side measures that were announced by the
chancellor that day and it was only
after that that you know when markets
reacted very uh negatively so much of
what causing quote taken said in terms
of his unfunded tax cuts that there was
a sort of reappraisal but
um you know business wants stability
certainty investment
um it's an open question with so many of
um the treasury's tax policies you know
seeming to change from one week to the
next
um how much of that we're actually going
to get from this Administration yeah and
and Ian we've only got 30 seconds left
very briefly pensions where are we with
that because that was obviously a big
concern last week yeah I mean the bank's
intervention was decisive I was talking
to a fund manager last night who said
The Guild Market actually froze there
with no guilds changing hands at the
long end of the maturities uh 20 and 30
years the the intervention has unfrozen
the guilt Market although it's worth
pointing out Gil yields are still higher
than they were prior to the bank's
intervention and other maturities in
Mark Sam and Ed thank you all very much
that was a Sky News Cost of Living
special program thanks very much for
watching all the rest of the day's news
come up at one o'clock